mientras la mayor parte del planeta
celebraba el fin del 2019 una nueva
amenaza energía el 31 de diciembre de
2019 China alertó a la Organización
Mundial de la Salud de 27 casos de una
neumonía viral de origen desconocido
identificados en la ciudad de Wuhan lo
que semana es más tarde sería catalogado
como el charkov dos virus que produce el
covid-19 oficialmente el primer caso de
la gripe de Wuhan fuera de China se
registró en Tailandia el 13 enero 2020 y
rápidamente se extendió por todo el
mundo
es desarrollo y distribución de una
vacuna dividió la opinión pública siendo
la OMS principal promotor de la
inoculación fecha que más de 9000000 de
2 si se han administrado mundialmente en
un año las autoridades sanitarias se
lamenta no haber alcanzado las metas
propuestas
online
maticas y graves son los que no se han
vacunado una vez que las mascarillas y
el testeo ya son un denominador en las
culturas de todo el mundo la OMS confía
en que el 2022 ponga fin a la fase aguda
de la pandemia